IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Hi everyone.
I am Ibrahim Ulukaya from
YouTube's API Developer
Relations team joining
you from New York.
And today we are talking
about resumable uploads.
Resumable uploads is
an uploading protocol
for Google APIs.
It's easier to upload files
and save time and bandwidth
in any case that if
your file is uploading,
there is a transmission error
or a [INAUDIBLE] network error.
It's especially useful if you
are transferring large files,
or if you're on an
unreliable network,
or you are using a device
with a low bandwidth,
such as a mobile device.
This protocol is
already [INAUDIBLE]
in Google Libraries,
as well as you
can use the normal JSON request
as long as you know the URL.
So let's go to my laptop
and see [INAUDIBLE].
If you try to use the JSON, to
go over this design diagram,
you will first
initiate a request.
You will just first send the
POST metadata and the content
type you want to send.
So if you are
inserting a video, you
will say that you
sending video metadata
and the content type is a video.
Once your client
[INAUDIBLE] with the server
this request, if the
request is successful,
the server will return
back with a 200 response
with the location
of your upload.
So it will tell you the location
that your uploads will happen.
Using this location,
then you can actually
start sending uploads
either in chunks,
or you can upload only in
one request, in one chunk.
And you get to [INAUDIBLE]
on your content.
If you decide to
go on in chunks,
you will actually keep
receiving 308 requests
that you actually still
have more chunks to go.
Your chunk was successful.
And then if you only
upload one chunk,
or if you have many
chunks but you're
uploading the final chunk, once
the chunk is uploaded as well,
you will actually receive
a 200 successful response.
With this, you understand
the upload is successful.
And the other way, if your
upload was not successful,
we'll also cover
that point as well.
So let's go to the
developer pages,
developer.google.com/youtube,
and there is a guide over
there, using resumable uploads.
And let's see
examples from that.
So here's an example that you
just start with a POST request.
Here is the URL for
the POST request,
https://googleapis.com/upload/youtube/v3/videos.
And you just say upload
type is resumable.
You set its content length
as video content type.
And it's upload content
type as video type.
And you have the video metadata.
And if the session
was successful,
then it will return to
you with the location.
And using this location,
you are actually
sending a PUT
request [INAUDIBLE],
and put in your
binary file data.
It it's one chunk, then
you put it all like this.
Or if you want to
go and actually
chunk it into smaller
chunks, then you
can actually give
it a content range,
and say that you
are actually sending
that range of the bytes.
And you are actually
sending that bytes only.
So if everything was
successful, as we mentioned,
we are actually
returning a 200 request.
If actually your upload
was not successful,
but it can be still resumed--
your network could be down,
or you may have received
one of the error responses.
It could be one of the 500
responses, could be like 500
Internal Server Error, Bad
Gateway, Service Unavailable,
or Gateway Timeout.
But if your response was
one of the 400 responses
or any of the
other 500 responses
we didn't mentioned here, then
your upload could be failed.
The only way to check
it is actually you
are sending a PUT request.
But this time setting
its length to zero,
and content which
is bytes star slash.
So that content link, that
display-- you actually
understand that you are trying
to check the status of upload,
not try and upload more files.
In response, you
will actually get--
just as like any other
chunk upload responses--
you will get the range.
And you will understand to that
point which part of the file
was uploaded already.
But it may actually
return as a 404 response.
That means that your session
ID was already expired.
So by this way we will
suggest that once you
start the initiation request,
keep sending the upload chunks
right after that.
We already checked
in-- this was a JSON.
And if you want to actually
use just libraries,
it's almost for
[INAUDIBLE] libraries.
And here's a small diagram
explaining the resumable media
upload [INAUDIBLE].
That MediaHttpUploader
will actually
do the whole process for you.
You will only set the
uploads, and MediaHttpUploader
will take it from there.
It will send the HTTP request.
If it fails, it will
actually back off from there
and it will try again.
So let's see from
one of our examples.
And here is in our
github.com/youtube where all
our open source examples are.
So we create a media content
using our video file.
Then we want to create
an insert request.
And the insert request--
we put the metadata as well
as the media content, we
just get our video file.
Instead of just
executing this, we
use the MediaHttpUploader,
which is the object that
handles resumable uploads
for us, or uploads for us
in general.
So we get to the uploader.
And to make it resumable,
we setDirectUpLoadEnabled
to false, which means you
will use resumable uploads.
Now once we execute,
the media uploader
will take over and do
the resumable uploads.
You can even implement
the progressListener
with the
MediaHttpUploaderProgressListener
object and keep track
of the progress.
You can even-- if you
deep dive from there
you will be able to see that.
You can actually get the
percentage of your upload
and you can show it in your app.
And that's all I
want to cover today.
We just go over how to
upload the resumable upload
either from JSON
or through using
one of our client libraries.
As always I want to plug
the Developer Relations
team, either in YouTube
or in other departments,
we are hiring almost
everywhere in the world.
You can always check it from
developers.google.com/jobs.
And this is Ibrahim
Ulukaya from New York.